Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Okay, guys. Hope you
guys we're here in Manchester. We came
here with the Salah Project as you can
see teaching people how to pray Salah.
We had our sister, what's your name?
>> Sumea.
>> Sister Sa [laughter] alhamdulillah. He
wanted to ask a question. Yeah.
>> She came here with her cameras, but I
thought, you know what, the sound's not
going to be good. So, we thought we'll
film for her and in make it a message
that reaches more people cuz it is a
common problem. So, repeat your
question. What was your question? Why is
women's modesty emphasized publicly and
excessively whilst men's modesty which
the Quran commands first is often
treated secondary? Like women is very
like obsessive like wear the hijab do
this whereas men's lower wearing gaze
which Allah says in the Quran is treated
as secondary. SO I DON'T understand like
why is it different?
>> I think that's that's a good question. I
don't know if in the Quran Allah
mentions one's modesty over the other.
Allah said so the believing lawyers gays
and the belie as well. So that is
important as well. So I believe there's
a lot of double standards. So we got two
extremes. We've got the red pill and
we've got toxic feminism. So toxic
feminism, red pill are the same thing.
That's the reason why it's important as
men and we we should point this out as
well because there is this big thing
about da bros this dow bros that. But
I'll be like 10 years ago I've been
talking about this topic where I was the
first YouTuber who actually spoke about
men's hijab because if you look at
modesty and hayman you know
he was so modest. He has so much hay.
Subhan Allah. Like even the prophet
would cover himself next to him. So
modesty and hay is something that is
connected to the sisters when it
shouldn't be because modesty and hay is
for myself. The way I observe, what I
look at, the way I dress, I can't dress
in tight clothes. I have to cover from
my neighbor to my knee. So a lot of me
that needs to go to the brothers is that
sometimes you get these brothers who are
criticizing sister's hijab or his pink
color, one single hair strand showing.
But it's the same brother he goes
topless on holidays. So I agree with you
and you're right. Allah does tell the
believing man and the believer to cover
up. That's true. But one thing we need
to bear in mind is this sister. We as
men are visual creatures. Yes. Because
we're visual creatures. It's also we
have to do our part. As men we should
lower our gaze. But the question is this
sister. Are women doing their part by
covering up? And another issue that we
miss is what? Makeup.
>> Yes. Okay.
No no no no. I'm not talking about you.
I'm not talking about you. [laughter]
I'm talking about you. I'm talking in
general. What what's happening is a lot
of sist
correct. But a lot of sisters what
they're doing is when it comes to
beautifying theirel you see them like
fully take up and it's like okay hold on
a second it's true as men we should
lower our gates it's true that there are
men in the Islamic sphere who are always
picking on sisters which is wrong.
However would you agree that also
sisters right in these days have got
full makeup on and they are out there
beautifying theirel.
>> I find fair enough like women like yeah
some of them they do wear makeup and
etc. But the thing is right men they
should be around. I look okay. I love
>> true but that doesn't mean that okay
look I should know my case but that
doesn't mean for example that our
sisters should also you know
>> you know what I'm trying to say we have
to be fair they both have to do this job
because if we say if if if the argument
is lower in the gates that means okay
let our sisters walk half naked because
we're lowering our gates we're doing our
bit so nobody will look at them no we as
both that's what Allah says to the
believing man is gay and the woman as
well so we both have to do our part
>> also you know the how far does it go
from there cuz you know how um women
wearing the posting themselves house
like I like a friendly can't do that
because like men are going to be tempted
or just something Allah Allah doesn't
say in the Quran apparently [laughter]
the hood in the hood apparently men are
going to be tempted
>> why are you going No I'm not
>> you want to go on camera
>> no I don't want to go on camera you want
to come a bit close because I can't hear
you won't be on camera I I'll avoid you
>> okay thank you but it's the conversation
and it's the way that it's it's talked
about especially with like Da brothers
the way that they the way they talk
about modesty, the way they talk about
modesty with hijabs, the way like for
I'm not trying to like asaf I don't mean
to be like bad towards you or anything
but recently you were in a you were in a
scandal with this lady over talking
about her eyelashes and it was just the
way you the way just the attitude by
which there so many of you speak about
the hijab and so many of you speak about
women. It's just like if I didn't read
the Quran and if I didn't know Islam the
way I know Islam, I would not be drawn
towards Islam just from seeing so many
clips about of like Da brothers and just
the way you speak. Like it's just I
think that the attitude needs to be
changed and you need to like think about
the effect of what of the things that
you say to the people who are in the
religion and people outside the religion
as well. LIKE SO MANY TIMES I WANT TO
PUT ON MY HIJAB AND I I'LL FEEL FINE,
you shouldn't WEAR MAKEUP, BUT HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO ADDRESS IT? HOW are you
going to How are you going to tell us
not to wear makeup? How you going to are
you going to say no no no YOU I DON'T
YOU YOU'VE GOTTEN YOURSELF A FREE TICKET
to hell. That kind of situation is not
necessary.
>> It's not true. I don't think anyone can
doom anyone to hell. That's that's h not
permissible. But the question I ask you
is who is the da bros?
>> The da bros. OKAY. NEVER TELL ME HOW
IMPORTANT LIST. OKAY. You know no let me
tell you the da bros. Who's I want to
know what is a da bro?
>> A da bro it's like these MEN THAT ARE SO
OBSESSED with women
>> who what's that can be any Muslim man
bros
>> okay no when you say da bros I need to
know who that for so so so the question
I'm asking this sister is what is a da
bro because because you know what's
happening now people who do food reviews
and become a da bro you're a random
Muslim guy who's a mechanic become a da
bro anyone that opens their mouth become
a da bro girl bro now you know in the da
scene there specific people me hijab
even by Amen. You can say okay. Yes. But
so what I'm saying is this is stuff if
we if we label Can you give it
[laughter] to cuz I want to Yeah,
please. Yeah. Cuz the thing is this we
we talk about like for example Yes.
Right. the way we deliver it. But the
thing is why is it that when we for
example say to our sisters, why are you
guys wearing makeup? That's also haram.
Automatically we're misogynist.
Automatically this. You said to me,
shouldn't men talk about their modesty?
I said you're right. Shouldn't we talk
about our slower in our gates? I said
you're right. But why is it when we say
true sister, but how our sisters dress
up and then wearing makeup, isn't that
also another issue we should have? All
hell gets broke loose.
>> No, it's because like I [laughter] don't
know. It's just like the emphasis on
like women like you do this thing like
the hell like
>> I agree. I But but but let me tell you
something sister. I've got videos from
10 years ago where I have spoken out
against other Muslim men who are like
I'm like why are you obsessed with
women's hijab? Why don't you talk about
you topless on holidays? I've done this
I've spoken about this long time ago.
I've done an experiment called men's
hijab tutorial. I spoke to men how to
conduct their self. But nobody talks
about that. So my job I've always been
fair. I talk to sisters. I talk to
brothers as well. So what I'm saying is
this. There shouldn't be there shouldn't
be a divide between me and you. We are
we are Allah says in the Quran we are we
are to one another. You are my sister in
Islam. If I saw someone harming you down
the road, I will put my life on the line
for you. Not because you're blood
related. Because not because you're my
sister biologically because you're not.
Because they say blood is thicker than
water. Do you know what that means?
>> Yeah.
>> Blood means your brother is your blood.
Right. In Islam, we believe iman is
thicker than blood. Meaning what your
brother will do for you, I will do for
you cuz you're my sister in Islam. And
the same should be with us.
>> Okay. Fair enough. Oh, does she have a
question?
>> Yes.
>> Regarding the question about
>> You come close. I can't hear you.
>> Okay. But I don't
>> you look look I'll blur you. You'll be
on.
>> Okay. Regarding.
>> No. Too many people are recording.
>> I'll blur you.
>> Okay.
Regarding the question on who da bro
girls are at the end of the day when
like so many Muslim men see the type of
people who are on the top for example
you and other people
>> what's what's a da bro
>> the people who speak da is to spread
Islam
>> good no no no what is a da bro if I come
and say hey hijabi sis that's all of you
guys so what's a da bro do you agree I'm
I'm a da bro
>> yeah good muhammad hijab
>> yeah akan yeah
>> good who else is a da bro
>> podcast people no no no No, no, no, no,
no, no. One second. You know what you
found? It's like imagine you do dawa,
you wear hijab. Then I start saying
there's these other sisters who do weird
stuff and I put you in their category
and I go, you hijabi sisters. Why?
Because they wear a hijab like you. Is
that fair?
>> No.
>> Good. There are people who do food
review. They became a da bro. There's a
mechanic, Muslim mechanic. He's a da
bro. Everyone's become a da bro. There's
specific people in the da. Have you seen
me ever ever come and criticize a woman
about her hijab?
>> No.
>> Good. You know why? I have talked about
people who took off their hijab, but I
never attacked them because of the
hijab. But what I'm saying is sister is
this thing that's popularized that oh
throws this, thou bros that. And I mean,
where does this come from? We've always
defended our sisters when we need to. We
defended our brothers. But I'm not a a a
um a person who's going to show up my
religion. Do you not agree we have a
problem with so many sisters wearing
makeup and beautifying the self on Tik
Tok?
>> Yeah.
>> Should we not talk about that?
>> We can't. I'm just saying it's the way
that people speak.
>> 100%. You are 100% right. [laughter] And
I believe the way I spoke before was
wrong and I apologize. I said if the
delivery was wrong, I put my hands up. I
said, "I'm sorry."
>> Thank you for
>> But do you agree that sisters
beautifying theirel is haram?
>> Yes.
>> No one's no one's arguing that it's not
haram. And no one is talking.
>> But that's not what I'm saying. My point
is the delivery can be so 100%. That's
why Allah says in the Quran, if you was
to be harsh to them, they would have run
away from you. And I 100% agree with
you.
So thank you. There we go. So we are
sisters and brothers. We are one brother
and sisters. This gender wars and this
kind of stuff that are trying to divide
us. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
This gender wars and stuff that's trying
to divide us. This is our concern. We
address alhamdulillah. And inshallah we
are not against each other. We are
brothers and sisters questions.